[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia kobe 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa
vamos a hablar de los recientes o las
recientes decisiones que ha tomado el
gobierno de eeuu allí el presidente joe
biden anunció que para enfrentar el pico
de casos de contagio a causa de la
variante delta fue impuesta la
vacunación obligatoria para los
empleados federales y también para las
empresas de gran tamaño por ejemplo las
automotrices o la industria aeronáutica
las personas que no lo hagan van a ser
sometidas a pruebas semanales de pcr y
en el caso de las empresas van a tener
que pagar múltiples multas vamos también
a hablar de chile porque el instituto de
salud de ese país aprobó el uso de
emergencia de la vacunas y novak para
los menores de 6 años hubo opiniones
divididas unos pidieron que fuera usada
en mayores de 12 años y otros esperan
hasta tener más antecedentes científicos
para determinar si la pueden usar o no
la decisión debe ser ratificada por el
ministerio de salud tenemos los detalles
desde la ciudad de santiago con nuestra
corresponsal y también vamos a hablar
tal y como lo prometió el nuevo
presidente guillermo la zone superó los
9 millones de personas vacunadas en sus
primeros 93 días de gobierno siete días
antes de esos 100 días que había
prometido las autoridades también
llevaron a cabo un sentido homenaje a la
comunidad médica ya los científicos que
han hecho frente a la crisis sanitaria a
lo largo de todo este año y medio tal
vez un poco más de adversidades también
que ha traído la pandemia de kobe 19
este país allí también está avanzando la
vacunación para los menores de edad
veremos entonces cómo está el panorama
general de este país suramericano vamos
a comenzar entonces con las cifras lo
hacemos con el avance que ha tenido la
pandemia a lo largo de esta semana en el
continente americano vamos entonces a
ver una actualización de algunos de los
números de fallecidos y de los casos
reportados en algunos países de nuestro
continente vamos a comenzar con canadá
en el extremo norte allí en registran
más de 1.5 millones de casos ya
confirmados los fallecidos superan los
27 mil un poco más al sur en colombia
contabilizan 4.9 millones de casos 5
millones de casos ya van a llegar en los
próximos en los próximos días incluso en
unas cuantas horas mientras que el
vecino panamá cuenta con más de 461 mil
casos y los fallecidos ya superan los
siete mil cien paraguay un poco más al
sur reporta para el cierre de esta
semana más de 459.000 casos y las
víctimas mortales superaron las 16 mil
finalizamos en argentina en donde ya hay
5.2 millones de casos oficialmente
reportados y más de 113 mil personas han
fallecido
como lo decíamos importantes anuncios
tuvieron lugar en eeuu a lo largo de
esta semana en donde el repunte de
contagios y también la baja tasa de
vacunación llevó a tomar algunas
decisiones por parte del presidente joe
biden quien ha ordenado que los
empleados federales y también de las
empresas de gran tamaño tengan que tener
vacunación obligatoria veamos
eeuu quiere acabar con la reticencia de
los anti vacunas cerca de 80 millones de
personas aún no se han vacunado contra
el kobe 19 en el país que ahora sufre un
repunte de contagios algo que está
agotando la paciencia del presidente yo
vaivén mi mensaje a los estadounidenses
que aún no están vacunados es igual que
están esperando whiteford
que más necesitan ver
y vamos a echar las vacunas gratuitas
seguras y convenientes sin
la vacuna ha recibido la aprobación de
la f1 y más de 200 millones de
estadounidenses han recibido al menos
una dosis
hemos sido pacientes pero nuestra
paciencia se está agotando para acabar
con los estragos que está causando la
variante de alta el demócrata anunció la
vacunación obligatoria para todos los
empleados del gobierno federal requirió
que las empresas con más de 100
empleados inoculen o hagan pruebas
semanales a su plantilla y que las
corporaciones que trabajan con el estado
inmunicen a todos sus trabajadores los
gobiernos locales también están
implantando normativa al respecto los
ángeles exigirá la vacuna a los
estudiantes mayores de 12 años y es que
la situación del cob y 19 en eeuu sigue
siendo alarmante los casos están
aumentando y las hospitalizaciones y
muertes casi duplican las de la misma
fecha del año pasado desde el ejecutivo
esta crisis sanitaria se achaca a los
que no se han vacunado que suman la
mayor de los positivos
vamos ahora la consulta con el doctor de
carlos eduardo perez ese médico
infectólogo asesor científico de france
24 como siempre un gusto tenerlo con
nosotros doctor para abrir nuestra
agenda de consulta y comienzo por
preguntarle por este tema que estábamos
presentando en este reportaje y es esa
decisión de eeuu de imponer la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación para los
empleados federales no se están violando
derechos es necesario tener la vacuna
obligatoria para poder llegar a esa
inmunidad y poder bajar estas tasas de
mortalidad y de contagio
santiago es importante entender que la
autonomía de los individuos es uno de
los principios de la ética y en la
autodeterminación de las personas pero
es que la vacunación no es un acto
individual es un acto colectivo cuando
las personas no se vacunan no se ponen a
riesgo ellas mismas sino se ponen a
riesgo las demás personas esta variante
del está e incluye que las personas que
así estén inmunizadas si una persona las
contagia se pueden enfermar entonces me
parece que hay que tomar decisiones que
sean muy sensatas pero que además de la
fase de educativa también se se estimule
la vacunación positivamente porque vemos
que el retraso de la vacunación lo único
que quiere es han tener nuevos picos
nuevos fallecimientos y no vamos a
lograr superar la pandemia entonces si
hay que buscar alguna forma de entender
que la vacunación no es un acto
individual sino de responsabilidad
social sin embargo sigue generando
muchos debates doctores sobre todo para
las personas que no están de acuerdo con
las vacunas ya vemos el debate qué
precisamente se está dando en eeuu pasó
a preguntarle por otro tema de
importancia en la región y es la
variante mucho que ya la autoridad
europea que tengo el término exacto la
considera como una variante
potencialmente preocupante esto qué
quiere decir entonces de cara al
desarrollo del virus de cara al
desarrollo de esta variante del
desarrollo de la pandemia como tal qué
significa
las variantes suceden en toda la
dinámica de la pandemia cuando una
variante es de interés es porque se
empiezan a analizar si es más
transmisible si escapa a las vacunas si
además de eso tiene mayor probabilidad
de mortalidad cuando ya se llama
navegante de preocupación es porque
alguno de estos ítems ya sea la
transmisibilidad del escape la respuesta
inmunológica o la letalidad se ve
involucrada algunas de los estudios han
mostrado que es probable que esta vacuna
escape al sistema inmune es decir a la
fabricación de los anticuerpos por la
vacuna o la inmunidad natural que
adquirimos y por eso ya se empieza a
preocupar qué significa esta
preocupación que hay que reforzar las
medidas para controlar que no haya esta
variante y hacer estudios clínicos para
ver si hay necesidad de hacer
intervenciones terapéuticas con esta con
esta variante en la medida que haya
personas susceptibles van a ver más
variantes y esta variante entra a ser de
las grandes preocupación por la
posibilidad de escapar a la respuesta
inmunológica fabricada por los seres
humanos unas o paul inmunidad natural
doctor pérez viendo las cifras de varios
países de suramérica se nota un descenso
en cuanto a los casos de contagio y
también en la cantidad de personas que
está siendo hospitalizada debido al cob
y 19 tal parece que la región está en
una bajando de la ola por fin de esta
cresta que tuvimos al
más o menos a la mitad del año pero
vemos el avance de la variante muy que
ya lo estamos mencionando que ya poco a
poco va cobrando más importancia para
las autoridades científicas y médicas a
nivel internacional está la región en un
punto de bajada de la cresta pero
estamos entonces
aproximándonos a un nuevo pico de
contagio con la predominancia que pueda
llegar a tener la variante mo en la
región que se está expandiendo muy
rápido como lo ve usted qué análisis
hace
es importante como dos momentos la
variante miel no es una variante que
esté circulando ahora es se describió en
colombia que es distinto a que sea
colombiana es donde se describió
inicialmente a principios del año y fue
responsable al menos de la mitad de los
casos y explica por qué en colombia pudo
haber sido ese tercer pico tan
prolongado la expresión de esta variante
sin embargo la variante delta comparada
con esta variante mundo es mucho más
contagiosa mucho más transmisible
entonces y la mayoría de los países de
la región no tenemos presente la
circulación delta esta variante me va a
empezar a circular en los países en las
regiones ya está escrita en más de 43
países pero es muy probable que sea la
variante delta en la que pueda llegar a
la cuarta ola que estamos esperando a
finales de este año y que se une con
estas otras variantes por eso el llamado
a la vacunación ya sabemos que las
vacunas funcionan efectivamente las
personas no vacunadas se enferman las
vacunas pueden transmitir el virus pero
enferman muy poco y estas variantes lo
único que nos debe hacer es acelerar los
puestos de vacunación
latinoamérica solamente lleva el 25 30
por ciento de la vacunación necesitamos
duplicar la vacunación al final del año
para que estas variantes no nos afecten
en un pico más letal como ha pasado en
regiones en otras regiones o lo que pasó
en la región
a principios de este año este países que
van muy adelantados como por ejemplo
chile y uruguay pero hay otros países
que se están quedando atrás que han
tenido dificultades para recibir los
lotes de vacunas muchas gracias doctor
por esta consulta un poco más rápida
tenemos muchos temas hoy en el programa
le agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros en el día de hoy precisamente
vamos a hablar de lo que ha dicho la o
ms que le ha pedido a los países más
ricos al a nivel mundial que no inoculen
la tercera dosis de refuerzo para
algunos sectores de su población y que
donen estas vacunas a los países que
están rezagados en la inmunización
no queremos más promesas solamente
queremos las vacunas juli vaccinated
este es el enésimo llamado del
presidente de la organización mundial de
la salud para que los países ricos dejen
de administrar dosis de refuerzo contra
el cob y 19a sus poblaciones mientras
muchos países pobres prácticamente no
tienen acceso a las vacunas un llamado
que asegura ha caído en oídos sordos
five point bill and boxing rose having a
duscher que se han administrado 5500
millones de dosis de vacunas pero el 80%
se ha administrado en países de nivel
medio alto y alto el objetivo mundial de
la oms ese sigue siendo ayudar a todos
los países a vacunar al menos al 10% de
su población a finales de este mes
'la es fortí persona al menos al 40 por
ciento a finales de año y al 70% de la
población mundial a mediados del próximo
año casi el 70% de los países ricos han
vacunado completamente al 40% de sus
habitantes pero ninguno de los países
pobres ha logrado vacunar siquiera al
10% de su población y esto holding al
disenso es el acaparamiento de estos
materiales que vimos al principio de la
pandemia pero no sólo es injusto no sólo
es inmoral sino que está prolongando la
pandemia y está provocando muertes
tenemos suficientes vacunas en todo el
mundo si hubiéramos utilizado las dosis
de vacunas disponibles de otra manera
estaríamos en una situación muy
diferente ahora mismo efecto
el acaparamiento de vacunas ha sido
justamente uno de los principales
motivos por los cuales el mecanismo
kóvacs impulsado por la o ms no ha
podido cumplir con sus objetivos en el
suministro de dosis a países pobres la
entidad espera va a proporcionar al
menos dos mil millones de dosis a países
con escasos recursos este año y ya ha
reducido este objetivo a 1.425 millones
ya que estamos hablando de vacunación
veamos cómo cierra el avance de esta
semana en algunos países de la región
les presento el porcentaje de población
que ya tiene el esquema completo vamos a
comenzar nuevamente en canadá en donde
el 67 punto 88 por ciento de la
población ya tiene el esquema completo
en costa rica cierran la semana con el
29 punto 70 por ciento de la población
alcanzó el 24 puntos 70 por ciento
uruguay que ya lo decíamos uno de los
líderes 72 puntos 76 por ciento y
finalizamos en trinidad y tobago con el
30 punto 34 por ciento
y ahora nos vamos hasta el sur del
continente vamos a ir hasta chile porque
allí el instituto de salud pública de
ese país aprobó el uso de emergencias de
la vacuna china sinovac para ser
inoculada en menores de edad en menores
de 6 años ha habido todo tipo de
discrepancias ahí entre las autoridades
le vamos a preguntar a patricia luna
quien está en santiago para conocer más
detalles hola patricia como siempre un
gusto y cuéntenos que han dicho allí
sobre esta medida que ha tomado la
autoridad sanitaria chilena
hola a santiago el instituto de salud
pública chileno anunciaba el lunes la
autorización de uso de emergencia de la
vacuna china sinovac para niños mayores
de 6 años y por tanto también para niños
mayores de 12 años recordemos que en
chile el proceso de inoculación al
segmento de edad entre los 12 a los 18
años se había iniciado a finales de
junio pero hubo de ser interrumpido ante
la falta de suministro de la vacuna a
faisal con la que se estaba realizando
el ministro de salud enrique parís
anunció que este proceso se va a retomar
en las próximas semanas pero lo que está
claro es que a partir del lunes se
empezará a vacunar a niños de 11 años
con comorbilidades previas chile lleva
bastante avanzado el proceso de
vacunación de una población objetivo de
15 2 millones de personas frente a los
19 millones de chilenos se ha logrado
vacunar a un 90% de la población con una
dosis ya un 87 por ciento de esa
población con dos dosis o sistema
completo además en paralelo se realiza
un proceso de inoculación a las personas
mayores de 55 años con una tercera dosis
o dosis de refuerzo esta vacunación
sería la que explicaría las buenas
cifras que se han registrado en el país
en las últimas semanas concretamente en
las últimas 24 horas poco más de 500
casos y una positividad dentro del país
menor al 1% algunas de las cifras más
bajas de toda la bandeña
gracias.patricia por este reporte desde
la ciudad de santiago si hago la
aclaración mayores de 6 años que tuve
hay una imprecisión pasamos ahora a
cuba- allí también los menores de edad
van a tener que recibir el esquema
completo de vacunación para poder
regresar a las clases presenciales en
las escuelas de ese país caribeño veamos
al igual que el día de siete años muchos
niños cubanos empiezan el nuevo curso
escolar sentados frente a una pantalla
la razón en cuba los niños no volverán a
los colegios presencialmente hasta
completar su pauta de vacunación decía
mi niña que yo le ha cuidado tanto no la
saco de pronto que salga sin estar
protegida eso para mí me tenía un poco
inquieta es mejor estar vacunado para
protegerse contra el kobe 19 que es
mejor prevenir que lamentar el sábado en
la isla se dio inicio a la inoculación
de menores de 2 hasta 18 años la primera
campaña de inmunización infantil del
mundo los menores recibirán dosis de las
vacunas desarrolladas nacionalmente
abdalá y soberana aún no reconocidas por
la o ms una decisión tomada tras
realizar ensayos clínicos infantiles y
conseguir luz verde del ente regulador
de fármacos tres resultados han sido muy
favorables
demostrándose que la vacuna en población
pediátrica también
tiene un perfil adecuado de seguridad y
una inmunogenicidad adecuada el país
caribeño pretende frenar así el alza en
contagios que enfrenta desde hace dos
meses y reabrir las escuelas cerradas
desde marzo del 2020
de cubanos vamos hasta perú en este país
a lo largo de la semana fueron
reportados varios casos de la variante
mu también el presidente castillo hizo
un anuncio un poco anticipado dijo que
en este país suramericano comenzarían a
producir la vacuna rusa sputnik ve luego
salió algunas de las autoridades a decir
que no era cierto porque no hay
infraestructura para hacerlo todavía
tienen que construir los laboratorios
para para poder desarrollarla allí
localmente vamos a conocer más detalles
con francisco zacarías quien estaban nos
acompaña desde la ciudad de puerto
maldonado en el departamento de madre de
dios francisco hablemos de la variante
muy los casos que se han registrado allí
adelante
santiago las autoridades peruanas
revelaron en su más reciente reporte que
la variante de mud acumula un total de
99 casos que se registran en estas
regiones de este país lima madre de dios
desde donde les estoy informando y el
callao contabiliza en la mayoría de
casos con 51 17 personas enfermas el
instituto nacional de salud detalló que
una paciente falleció por una infección
de esta variante tenía 42 años sufría de
obesidad y no había recibido ninguna
dosis de la vacuna contra el kobe 19
algunos infectólogos han alertado que la
variante move les ha llamado la atención
porque se manifestó en algunos pacientes
vacunados contra el que un nuevo
coronavirus señalaron que al menos 10
habían recibido las dos dosis de la
vacuna en su mayor parte pzifer pero
ninguno de ellos presentó una afección
de gravedad según el ministerio de salud
la variante predominante hasta el
momento de perú es la lambda con tres
mil 392 casos seguida de gamma con mil
299 y delta con 244 casos
francisco hablemos de esa controversia
que desató el presidente castillo que
dijo que empero iban a empezar a
producir la vacuna rusa sputnik vez
después de haber llegado a un convenio
con el instituto gamma leia en rusia
pero tal parece que las cosas no pueden
ser así porque no hay infraestructura en
perú para poder desarrollar esta vacuna
localmente que es lo que han dicho las
autoridades que fue lo que pasó
exactamente
el presidente de pedro casi o anunció
que tras negociaciones entre los
gobiernos de perú y rusia se instalará
una planta para la producción de la
vacuna sputnik
contra el cobre y 19 pero conservando el
entusiasmo y con los pies en tierra
suministro de salud fernando ceballos
reveló que todavía no existe un
porcentaje específico de dinero que le
correspondería desembolsar a los rusos
para financiar el proyecto sin
infraestructura y tecnología el
ministro- ceballos reconoció que no va a
ser fácil para perú implementar la
planta de vacunas y no cree que ésta
pudiese estar funcionando entre el 2023
de otro lado y con argumentos sólidos
arnoldo tipiani decano del colegio
químico farmacéutico del perú afirmó que
el país se encuentra lejos de fabricar
vacunas también advirtió que la
implementación tomaría un periodo de 5
años más o menos también recomiendo a
las autoridades invitar a la industria
privada al proyecto porque se encuentra
más actualizada respecto al diseño de
plantas con buenas prácticas de
manufactura paso ahora preguntarle
francisco por el panorama general
vacunados fallecidos casos de contagio
vacunados como avanzado y la situación
contando con alrededor de 2 millones 160
mil casos confirmados y casi 199 mil
fallecidos por kobe 19 pero la lista
para noviembre a la vacunación de
adolescentes de 12 a 19 años aunque en
algunas regiones como cusco y tacna se
adelantarán para impulsar el retorno a
las aulas de estudiantes en edad escolar
en paralelo además de la inmunización a
ciudadanos de 17 años que residen en
lima las autoridades sanitarias
comienzan la inoculación de pacientes
con diabetes tipo 1 y 2 así como quienes
tienen obesidad tipo 3 el ministerio de
salud ha informado que más de 8 millones
y medio de peruanos ya cuentan con las 2
dosis de la vacuna y la proyección es
aumentar la cifra a 14 millones a fines
de septiembre hasta el momento se han
aplicado 19,2 millones de fármacos de
los laboratorios facer scinopharm y
astrazéneca gracias a francisco por este
reporte desde puerto maldonado en el
oriente peruano muchas gracias por este
reporte a continuación veamos cuáles son
las variantes predominantes en algunos
de los países de la región o de nuestro
continente americano vamos a comenzar de
nuevo en el norte en canadá allí
más representativa es la del tacón el 95
punto 24 por ciento de los casos
registrados en las últimas dos semanas
también hay presencia de la variante
gama y alfa en eeuu el 100% de los casos
registrados allí en las últimas dos
semanas son delta en méxico también la
delta es predominante con el 98 punto 23
por ciento de los casos en chile si hay
mucha más diversidad la mayoría de las
variantes juntas darle una en el 50 y
1.16 por ciento le sigue gama lambda y
delta con solamente el 2.33 por ciento
brasil el gigante suramericano allí la
variante gamma representa el 64 punto 47
por ciento de los casos le sigue delta
con el 35 punto 22 por ciento de los
casos
y tal y como lo habíamos dicho en los
titulares el presidente de ecuador laso
prometió vacunar a 9 millones de
ecuatorianos en los primeros 100 días de
su gobierno lo hizo incluso antes y
recordemos que ecuador era un país que
estaba rezagado en la vacunación a nivel
continental vamos a conocer más detalles
y otras noticias también que tuvieron
lugar a lo largo de esta semana con
gustavo ortega en la ciudad de quito
gustavo comenzamos por esa buena noticia
9 millones de vacunados una meta
cumplida ecuador estaba relegado a nivel
internacional en la vacunación pero se
pone al día
hola qué tal santiago en efecto tal y
como tú has dicho el gobierno
ecuatoriano celebra sus primeros 100
días de gestión en un acto realizado
frente a la sede de la presidencial
palacio de carondelet en este país el
ejecutivo recordó que pasó del 4% de la
población cuando comenzó su gestión al
52% de la población vinculada con las 2
dosis del bioquímico hasta la fecha su
principal propuesta de campaña de
vacunar a 9 millones de personas en los
primeros 100 días de gobierno se
contabiliza hasta la fecha 9 millones y
medio de personas específicamente el
presidente de la república guillermo
lasso anunció que esperan alcanzar la
inmunidad de rebaño con al menos el 85%
de la población vacunada hasta el mes de
diciembre igual forma además informó que
ecuador buscará producir y distribuir
sus propias vacunas en la región una
nueva fase de vacunación que contemplará
llevar tienen las dosis principalmente
las zonas inaccesibles del territorio
nacional en otros temas se anunció que
ecuador buscará desarrollar acuerdos de
libre comercio con las diez principales
economías
el mundo la aplicación de los impuestos
destinados para el 4% de la población
que gane más de mil dólares mensuales ha
dicho que serán estos los que pagarán el
costo de la pandemia esto como parte de
un nuevo acuerdo de renegociación con el
fondo monetario internacional para poder
responder a ese embolsó hasta el año
2022 y adelantó que habrá reformas en el
campo laboral en mercado de valores
reformas en el sector de hidrocarburos
de energías de electricidad y
telecomunicaciones entre otros se
anunció que era próximamente el primer
mandatario gustavo también destacado
esta semana ese homenaje que dieron las
autoridades ecuatorianas a todo el
personal médico al personal del sector
de salud que ha estado trabajando en la
primera línea de frente a lo largo de
toda esta emergencia sanitaria y
recordemos que ecuador al principio tuvo
momentos muy disip muy difíciles sobre
todo en guayaquil cuando había algunas
personas que tenían que dejar los
cuerpos de sus familiares simplemente en
el frente de las casas porque no había
cómo atenderlos
así de santiago el gobierno ecuatoriano
también homenajeó de manera sin pública
a las personas fallecidas durante la
pandemia en ecuador de igual forma
también con un minuto de silencio y con
prendas de rosa frente a la sede
presidencial se reconoció la labor de
los médicos en primera línea la ministra
de salud ximena garzón anunció que a
partir de la primera semana de octubre
se entregarán 4.000 nombramientos para
personas en sectores salud lo que
significa en plazas de trabajo para este
sector una de las principales quejas de
el personal de la salud como parte de la
tan cuestionada ley humanitaria a más de
un año de su crecimiento y este texto
legal aseguró que esta era la mejor
forma de honrar al sector salud ecuador
ha disminuido sus tasas de mortalidad en
los últimos tres meses pasando del 14
como 35 en casos desde el mes de abril a
ubicarse en el 10 69 por ciento de los
casos por cada 100.000 habitantes la
tasa de positividad también llegó al 9%
en la última semana de agosto del
presente año esto quiere decir que 9 de
cada 100 personas
pruebas que se realizan de que hoy día
se hubieran positivo en el país en este
momento en la cifra más baja registrada
en el país desde el inicio de la
pandemia en marzo del año 2020 según las
autoridades esta cifra ha permitido un
descongestionamiento de unidades de
cuidados intensivos
hospitalización y la atención de otras
patologías que estaban olvidadas a causa
de la pandemia pero en la pandemia no ha
terminado y la capital de control inah
sigue siendo la que acumula mayor número
de casos estos 19 seguido la provincia
costera de guayas además de otras 100
provincias como en las más afectadas en
el país andino
gustavo sin duda algunas cifras
alentadoras allí en ecuador a pesar del
panorama difícil que seguimos teniendo
la emergencia persiste muchas gracias
por este reporte vamos ahora a cambiar
de tema les cuento brevemente otras
noticias destacadas a lo largo de la
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa comenzamos en argentina que
recibió las esperadas primeras dosis de
el primer lote de la farmacéutica
pfiezer bayern tech después de una
controvertida negociación entre el
gobierno y esta farmacéutica generó
mucha polémica y en argentina no muy
lejos de allí en uruguay al otro el río
de la plata ya probaron ya la tercera
dosis de la vacuna de facer variantes
precisamente para las personas mayores
de 60 años uruguay es líder en la
vacunación como lo veíamos en las cifras
hace unos minutos y también en nuestra
región finalizamos en haití este país
rechazó un lote de 100 mil vacunas de la
farmacéutica astrazéneca que fue donado
por su vecina república dominicana las
autoridades haitianas tienen sus
reservas en cuanto a esta vacuna debido
a esos efectos secundarios que han sido
registrados en diferentes pacientes no
solamente en américa sino también en
algunos países europeos
y vamos a dar ahora un vistazo a la
situación en honduras en centroamérica
allí también la tasa de contagios y de
personas hospitalizadas por kobe 19 se
ha ido incrementando a lo largo de las
últimas semanas allí está kenia torres
quien desde tegucigalpa nos va a dar más
detalles hola kenia comencemos por las
cifras no son alentadoras 9 mil personas
ya han fallecido en ese país de américa
central
santiago como estas el panorama para
honduras a raíz de la pandemia del
govern y 9 no es nada alentador según
las últimas estadísticas del sistema
nacional de riesgo el número de muertos
y de contagiados sigue en ascenso los
últimos números que han dado es que más
de 9 mil 200 hondureños ya han fallecido
y más de 350.000 se han contagiado por
esta enfermedad esto pese a las intensas
campañas de vacunación para esta semana
que para el caso el ministerio de salud
tiene previsto inaugurar la quinta
jornada donde serán inoculados jóvenes
menores de 17 años y es que es esta la
población que en este momento está
siendo afectada a esto se debe sumar un
buen número de mujeres embarazadas que a
raíz de campaña de desinformación pues
no se han vacunado y son las que están
asistiendo contagiadas a los centros de
salud tenía punto clave la vacunación
como está avanzando hay en honduras
algunos países como república dominicana
les han donado lotes de vacuna ustedes
si de hecho estas campañas se han
intensificado en los últimos meses el
problema santiago radica en que las
vacunas llegaron demasiado tarde al país
y es ahí donde el colegio médico de
honduras ha criticado fuertemente a las
autoridades de salud al gobierno porque
empezaron estas gestiones demasiado
tarde obviamente honduras es uno de los
países más pobres del mundo y cuando
salió a la venta la vacuna no se
encontraba totalmente con los recursos
sin embargo los últimos meses se hizo un
contrato millonario con fighter se
adquirieron 4.5 millones de vacunas de
las cuales ya han llegado casi un millón
al país con esto se ha empezado a
inocular también ha llegado otra compra
de rusia con la espuma que ya se aplicó
la dosis a una y dos a la población y
además otros países como españa
república dominicana méjico el salvador
han hecho donativos importantes de
vacunas como modernas el mecanismo
también de ellos y de eeuu se adquirió
1.5 millones de vacunas modernas y son
las que se están aplicando así como la
astrazéneca bueno una muestra de
solidaridad por parte de los vecinos
bueno por lo menos del salvador y de
república dominicana quería para
terminar este reporte actualice nos en
cuanto a las restricciones que se
mantienen vigentes allí en honduras y
también pues preguntarle si ya la vida
comercial y social ya prácticamente
regresó allí en este país
centroamericano
si efectivamente se mantiene un toque de
queda de día de la noche a 5 de la
mañana sin embargo durante el día la
actividad comercial social es
completamente normal obviamente las
autoridades siempre están con campañas
de concientización para que la gente
siga usando su mascarilla y se mantengan
las medidas de bioseguridad sin embargo
para el caso se aperturó la actividad
deportiva con la liga profesional
hondureña pero el público asiste a los
estadios y aunque las autoridades han
dicho que sólo el 20% del aforo es
permitido la gente sigue llegando sin
control se disputó recientemente un
partido eliminatorio mundialista entre
las elecciones de honduras y estados
unidos sin ayer las autoridades del
sistema de riesgo autorizaron la venta
de 16 mil boletos pero había más de
20.000 personas en el estadio entonces
estas media no se están respetando y por
eso los médicos hacen el llamado a la
que continúen cuidándose porque esta
estadística sigue en aumento y aunque en
honduras la población elegible para la
vacuna es de 7 millones apenas se está
llegando a los 5 millones de personas
que se están aplicando la primera dosis
todavía no se llega ni al millón ya con
las personas con el ciclo completamente
establecido así que las estadísticas no
son nada favorables y el número de
contagiados de muertos sigue en aumento
pero se espera que con esta campaña
masiva de vacunación la situación
empiece a mejorar en el país esperemos
que así sea kenny a muchas gracias por
este completo reporte desde la ciudad de
tegucigalpa vamos ahora a ver en redes
otras noticias destacadas a lo largo de
esta semana y comenzamos con esta
publicación de france 24 punto com
impacto del cob y 19 es devastador en la
lucha contra otras enfermedades mortales
según el reporte que presenta varias
cifras negativas la pandemia ha afectado
la lucha contra enfermedades como por
ejemplo el sida la tuberculosis la
malaria en diferentes países del mundo y
cerramos
este reclamo de la ms que pide detener
la aplicación de la tercera dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 hasta final de
este año
el pedido lo ha hecho otra vez el
director general pedrosa among ebre
'jesús que criticó a la asociación de
fabricantes de productos farmacéuticos
por el acaparamiento y también la
inequidad en la repartición de vacunas a
nivel mundial
es todo hoy aquí en kobe 19 la semana de
américa nos encontramos la próxima
semana sigan cuidándose el kobe 19 la
mención las manos usen tapabocas y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]